look i've been talking about the machine
a lot right like it feels like whatever
the structure is that allows us to have
conversation that allows certain things
to get out there it does feel like it's
in flux in a much bigger way than usual
right there's the rogan story that you
all know about we're going to get to
more on that in just a second there's
this canadian trucker thing you can you
get this feeling suddenly that the
pushback against the machine is gaining
momentum and that is sort of why they're
calling us all of these horrible things
well jake tapper is a democrat he is a
democrat who pushes democrat policies
and is always trying to slam and slander
republicans or conservatives on his show
but he pretends to be a journalist here
he is talking about kids and opening
schools and vaccinations and tell me if
what he's doing here is just reporting
straight information or adding his
opinion into it one of the things that
that uh look this show has been talking
about the need to open school since the
summer of 2020 uh so i'm not against
that and we've been talking because
we've been following the science and
that's what the science have been saying
one of the things that's a little bit
frustrating is people demanding schools
be open people demanding that the
students don't have to wear masks
without acknowledging that most kids are
still not vaccinated if you want to it
seems to me you want to open the schools
as safely as possible
you know all the kids and teachers and
faculty and staff need to be vaccinated
that's the safest thing to do right
right you can't have it both ways you
can't not vaccinate your kids and also
want your kids to go to school
completely unencumbered
uh you know right now if you're looking
at children in the united states less
than as you said less than half of of
children who are eligible for vaccines
are vaccinated and remember no child
under the age of five in this country uh
is vaccinated uh you know last last week
there were two million uh uh cases in
kids
yeah did jay tapper just report that
straight or did you did he tell you what
his opinion about vaccinating children
is
i'll leave that for you to decide he
said that his show has been following
the science and since june of 2020
they've been telling people to open
schools now jake i don't know if you're
watching this but i would love to know
what study you're referring to that
suddenly said schools could open in june
of 2020 there were plenty of people
saying that we should have never closed
schools there was plenty of information
very very early on almost immediately
that the recovery rate for children was
something like 99.97
and that also included if they were the
ones that were getting sick actually
really sick
were had all sorts of other
comorbidities and other situations
involved so i don't know exactly what
he's talking about but he follows the
science but then you know he leads it so
the whole thing that they do is they
don't outwardly exactly say what they're
doing but then he's sort of like but you
know i i would pretty much say that you
know these kids aren't vast and if these
kids aren't facts wouldn't it be the
best thing to get these kids kids back
then the former fda chief there he makes
note that you know no kid under five is
vast um and that these young kids who
are
vast it's like well why can't they go to
school
have we had school outbreaks where
there's suddenly thousands and thousands
of dead kids we haven't fortunately
thankfully there's something known as
natural immunity but the entire machine
has pushed vaccines on us to the point
that no one can make sense of any of
this stuff and believe it or not guys
it's still moving
this is why i always say you have to
give the machine credit no matter how
much we push back no matter how much
evidence we show to expose the nonsense
it keeps pushing so we've got some info
from the daily wire here on what they
want to do now with kids a new report
states that the biden administration's
food and drug administration is pushing
pfizer and its partner biontech to
request emergency youth use
authorization for a vaccine for children
as young as six months
pfizer and its partner bioentec the
manufacturers of the vaccine are
expected to submit to the food and drug
administration as early as tuesday a
request for emergency youth use
authorization for the vaccine for
children six months to five years old
which would make it the first vaccine
available for that age group last friday
pfizer discussed updated trial data with
dr anthony fauci among other government
officials one administration official
told the post of a robust conversation
that three doses were likely more
effective than two shots adding but to
get to that three you have to get two
shots first there's interest in seeing
this move forward covet has basically
not affected children at all why
would you want the government to give
emergency authorization to a
pharmaceutical company to inject your
six-month-old with this vaccine if you
are a parent i literally
don't understand i genuinely don't
understand after these people have been
exposed as liars all along masks work
masks don't work you touch your face
more it doesn't do anything anyway
because of the little air pockets blah
blah blah fauci's emails telling his
friends to go on vacation and don't
worry about masks because they don't
work while he's telling us to double
mask
if you get the vaccine you won't get
cobit or transmit it that's what they
told us that's what biden told us that's
what cdc director wolenski told us
turned out not to be true why would you
be okay with the idea that the
government at this point
two years later
would get emergency access to a
pharmaceutical company would give
emergency access to a pharmaceutical
company that has been proven to either
have a faulty product or have lied about
it the entire time and yet millions of
parents are still going to do it
millions of parents are still going to
do it i'm not a parent yet but i cannot
imagine i genuinely cannot imagine
bringing my six-month-old child to the
doctor and being like yes inject them
with that stuff
that stuff from the people who lied
about everything all along oh the
government said they could push it
through real fast
yeah injected in the kid let me get
three more okay could you get that for
me
i think you get the point there guys